still
welcome to lsm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you so much for uh
for that warm welcome
i i appreciate it i hope you felt that
too
yes thank you thank you for the warmth
thank you
as uh i i think i just uh
mentioned briefly when we were backstage
this
and i don't said i don't think i framed
it like this but this maybe is what i
would call the unofficial
uh finale on the unofficial living black
history month here in denmark because
[Applause]
because in just three weeks we've had
trevor noah we've had angela davis
in conversation with renier lodge
and a couple of days ago we had barack
obama
now we have
you
i think i think we can say that i mean
fairly good company i think you are in
fairly good company would you uh would
you would you have dreamed that or many
years ago when you started getting
published first that that that would be
the lineup you were you were to round
off
yes
no no i'm kidding
no i'm joking
um no no no i don't think i didn't dream
in specifics
i i think i always my biggest dream was
to be read i wanted to write things
and i really hope that i would be read
that was really my biggest dream
i think it's safe to say that that is uh
that that is going fairly
well um
you were last him in 2014 eight years
ago to to talk about americana
is anyone in the room were they all were
they also there
we have
we have some some some repeaters here
that's always a good thing
um
a lot has happened in those eight years
and
um i think
if we are to sort of if you are to
reflect back on when you were sitting on
this stage last time
um
this
international bestseller had just come
out
the the space you were in then versus
the space you were in in now
how would you uh how what would you say
to that
well
well i wasn't a mother then that's
really been i think the
most
meaningful change in my life
um and i had my parents
my uncles um
and i think maybe i didn't have i think
i still believed in
in american democracy
um
that has changed
uh maybe i wasn't as yeah
i don't even remember i feel like the
pandemic just robbed me of my memory
yeah i don't remember anything before
locked down yeah
no no i know i know what you feel it's
like time is being yes it's being
stretched in in very weird ways
and time is something i would like us to
talk about um a little bit but i think
now you mentioned america as well and
and
and
i think for so many people
also here in denmark and scandinavia in
general
america has been something to aspire to
a place to look up to or to compare
yourself to um in in americana remember
when this came out and the
the
descriptions of etheremelo the main
character her meetings with sort of
american culture with
uh with her own blackness with with all
of these things
were were something that i think to so
many people here became a huge
reflection and a huge mirror
and now i also have time i've had
difficulty finding out
sort of what should we look towards in
in the u.s and with the same aspiration
where are your sort of
where are you looking towards if you
don't believe in american democracy per
se anymore what do you believe in in
america and if anything
you know i think it's fair to say that
the former president really
shook
my faith
in a country that i call my second home
and so many things that i thought could
never possibly happen in the u.s because
like you said the u.s was aspirational
for me my entire life growing up in
nigeria and so many things i thought
could never happen in the u.s and
suddenly they were happening and and i
think that kind of thing just shakes the
foundation of faith that you have in
something
and um and i think that it has
deeply and i'm going to even say
permanently
um
changed american politics
made it so much more polarized made it
so much more simplistic
and
so no i don't know that i don't i don't
i don't it's not very aspirational to me
anymore
so
yeah i don't know what is
um
yeah i don't know i mean i could tell
you people who i find inspirational
they're not americans
who are they well there's a congolese
doctor called dr denis mukwege
who um i'm just reading about him also
he's just the most fantastic human
in the world so he has done so much work
with women um
women who were
victims of of rape um during the war and
i'm just reading his book now and i
remember just thinking we live in a
world in which we are starved of heroes
and i found one
that's beautiful
i think
you might also have been a hero to a lot
of people in that context
i know
that some feel that that are sitting in
this audience because they've personally
told me uh in the days leading leading
up to this
um
and this conversation i think
or i have felt very much has been has
been awaited with with big anticipation
it was it was it was sold out really
quickly and it was
people have been on fire
um
literally
that's worrying
it kind of is
um
but
but now that you mentioned this sort of
this polarization i was i was i was
going to bring it up a little bit later
but i'm going to ask now because i think
it goes
it goes back to
to one of the first things that i
i remember sort of
from you which was uh your ted talk that
the danger of a single story that was
very impactful um and where you are
addressing
what it what if i'm paraphrasing now
what it does to someone to be sort of
only
um
only see a very specific reflection of
the world yeah
and then i i read a recent interview
with you where you
talked about
the i think you called it the danger of
sort of ideological purity um
that that that is this polarization
would you elaborate a little bit on that
because i think those are
sort of connected as a strand
i think you know i remember i was having
a conversation with a friend recently
and i said i don't even like watching or
reading the news in the u.s anymore
because
even the news is now ideological it's
almost as though
um objective fact doesn't exist anymore
and so i'll give you an example in the
u.s there's all of this talk about
something called critical race theory
which in many ways half the people who
say do not know what it means
the other half just think nobody should
talk about race
and it seems to me very strange because
for a country like the us i mean race is
the foundational
issue i think in america
and it just seems to me there are
objective facts of history there are
things that happen children should know
about those things
but somehow the conversation then
becomes
um if you're on one side of the debate
and
you have certain you have you have new
facts if you're on the other side you
have your facts and it's
you know it's not just boring it's also
very um
i don't know demoralizing
and
and i think also it is in fact possible
to occupy one ideological side and still
see a kind of value on the other side so
i like to know what people who do not
agree with me think
mostly just so that i can prove them
wrong right
but
but to be able to do that you need to
know what they think
and there's a kind of this kind of
purity that i think we now have where
not only are we all supposed to tour a
certain line but we're also supposed to
be perfect you know there is it seems to
me that you know curiosity is dying um
that capacity to be human and flawed
is also dying
i think that people uh
i think we live in a world that is so
much
less
forgiving
and i think that's
a sad thing but also as a creator i
worry about the kind of art and the kind
of literature that we will produce in 20
years
or so
because
um
because we are running away from the
truth in all kinds of ways
so so a child in the us today who isn't
taught
the fundamental basics of american
history
um and in 20 years that child wants to
tell stories
i don't know what stories that child
would tell about america there will be
lies
you know so i think yeah
and then how do you because i think
there are about there are many many very
direct comparisons in that sort of
narrative around that ideological purity
and that very sort of
polarized conversation that could also
be said about denmark and and how
conversations on on race uh is is
happening here as well
in in so far that one of the constant
things that we continuously have to do
is to say that it's an actual thing that
racism is a thing that this is you know
something that happens that we need to
prove
continuously continuously continuously
despite it being a historical fact
and it takes an emotional tool it does
it takes an emotional toll and and i
think we we you just briefly mentioned
that emotional toll that when you were
traveling and meeting black people all
over the world and especially in europe
you you felt that
how do you go about
sort of
exemplifying maybe or telling in your
stories
a truth that is either not told has not
been told before or can give that sort
of broadness of perspective or that
insight into to something that that
you've been missing yourself in art and
literature you know i think americana in
some ways answers that when i when i
went when i first went to the us you
know first of all i became black in
america because in nigeria i wasn't
black i hadn't
like we just don't think of ourselves as
black in nigeria because we're all
mostly black and
and we're too busy fighting about tribe
and religion so
but um
and i came to the us and i i realized
that i had this new identity
that had been giving to me whether or
not i wanted it and it was based on how
i looked
and not only did i have this new
identity this new identity came with a
lot of baggage many negative stereotypes
and for me coming from a place where
blackness really did not equal
inferiority
and i remember my initial reactions
being a kind of amused
contempt i thought these people are
crazy i mean why do you think black
people are inferior you know that sort
of thing
and then i started reading american
history to understand racism and race
and you know it's interesting because
the certain things that happen to you
when you don't quite know the nuances
and you know something is off but you
don't have the language for it
you know
and they're little things and sometimes
big things but anyway so when i started
reading i realized that in non-fiction i
could learn about racism in fiction not
so much because race is a subject in the
us that is still
it's changing a bit now but at the time
made people so uncomfortable
that in literature it was only looked at
in very oblique ways so sometimes i
would read a passage and think
are they talking about race or not you
know you just weren't sure so when i
started writing americana i wanted to
write
a book in which you would be sure that i
was talking about race right
and um really wanted to use my
experiences
wanted to hopefully kind of make it
funny in the way that many sad and
terrible things can have humor in them
and also really just wanted to to do
away with many of the
um
rules so for a long time i was a very
beautiful daughter of literature
so i would sort of follow all the rules
and suddenly i thought you know what
with americana i want
um i'm going to use bits of a blog where
i'm just going to editorialize you know
i just i was having fun actually writing
this
but also i think what i was hoping was
that i would
open a door to a conversation that i
thought was really important
which is
not only that um
there is a reality of racism in america
but also that it's important not to talk
about racism as though it's something
that happened in the past
you know it's not about slavery right i
mean i often say to people in the u.s
slavery was terrible it happened but
actually i'm talking about 10 years ago
you know i live in a state maryland
where
um
you know
15 20 30 years ago they were draining
swimming pools so that black families
would not swim so communities would
rather deprive themselves of swimming
just so that one black family wouldn't
swim
right in the 70s in boston you had
grown women white women who i'm sure
went home to hug and kiss their children
standing outside schools and hurling
insults at little black children and
what was the reason the children wanted
to go to school i mean you know you
think about these are things that are
very much present and so i wanted to
kind of
you know write a book that i hoped would
be honest and would open conversations
and i think my position as a person who
is black but not american
gave me a kind of um
i guess a kind of platform so in some
ways i i think that i'm always outside
i'm outside in the u.s i'm slightly
outside in nigeria so i think it gives
me
maybe a clearer view i guess
and um
and maybe also there's a slight
privilege in having that position
because
i think african americans i think
sometimes it's too easy to label african
americans
angry
which of course in itself is interesting
because if you have that kind of history
you better bloody be angry right
but so i think my position as a what i
call a non-american black
yeah i guess it's a platform i wanted to
use
and is that because i uh i actually i
just listened to uh
to to americana these last couple of
days as sort of as an audiobook i've
read it several times but i listened to
it this time and having those blog posts
that are in that book read out to you
is a very different oh
sorry
is it
is this audio bad or this is not
working in your hair
okay sorry okay thank you
should we test it hello hello hello can
you hear it
wonderful
no but i i feel like
those those blog posts are sort of
it's a very direct message that comes
out of them and it's some it's a very
direct message that it's different from
sort of the literary the the literary
tradition that you're also sort of
writing into
and i mean you have as part of
of of of your
um
of your overhead you know you've done
you've done talks you've done you know
ted talks you've done books you've done
short stories you've done a range of
different sort of
um
[Music]
texts or sort of of bits that can live
in different places
is that a is that a way of sort of
positioning that sort of being an
outsider being able to speak in a
different way in one form and then
go back and
and write in another way and then go out
again and do something different i mean
now that you put it so elegantly i want
to say yes
but actually i wasn't framing the
question very directly but it but it's i
don't think it's not conscious it's
never been and i should say that
the love of my life is literature i mean
the thing that i deeply love
is literature
and it's you know it's reading stories
it's writing them
and i really love
that the gray areas you know but at the
same time i think when you're
a love of literature
you're also a citizen right you're
always so person who lives in the world
so i'm a lover of literature i love the
gray areas but i also have a nigerian
passport
which means that i am forced to confront
the reality of um you know applying for
visas and people telling you you're
lying or actually the one of the times i
came to denmark i have to say this time
it was very good at immigration
shockingly because one time one time
that i came
and i love telling the story
so i give him my nigerian passport here
in copenhagen and he says why are you
here and i say i'm a writer and he says
writer
and he looks at the passport he says
step aside
and he kept me there for i don't know 30
minutes and i felt like a criminal and
so later i was very kindly um informed
that because denmark had a problem with
nigerian sex workers he must have
assumed i was a sex worker
so anyway this is just to say that
you cannot hide behind
being an artist you're an artist and
also a citizen and i think my art gave
me a platform
and there are things i care about as a
citizen and so i decided to use that
platform to talk about those things i
care about so i care as a child you know
i was the child who was very much a war
of injustice i was the child who would
think why is the domestic walker being
treated badly you know i was the child
who would ask questions i've always been
alert to
just what isn't right and what is
inhumane
and so my platform as a writer meant
that i could talk about those things so
i talked about you know how important it
is that we acknowledge and celebrate the
ways in which we're different how many
stories matter i am fiercely feminist in
my world view and i thought i would talk
about that um you know i discovered
racism in america and i thought yeah
write a novel about that so i mean it's
it's not so much i wish
i wish i'd i wish we lived in a world
that were a bit more
fair and just
and if we did
i wouldn't be doing ted talks i would
just be lying in bed reading poetry all
day right
right
i think i can uh
[Applause]
i would if you if you like poetry i
would i would recommend some of the
newer voices that are also happening
here that are that are also new voices
on on the stage who are also very uh
direct in writing about
about race in their poetry um there are
several examples mikas lang for one who
is who's translated notes on grief into
danish
there are several several several people
in this back
one thing
though that i that i that i would ask
you now that we've spoken about your
work and we've spoken about um sort of
how you position yourself
is to ask you to read it for us a little
bit
um because i thought that would be nice
and um this now that we have you here
and this little this
this section from americana
um
is
and i've i've readily pointed it out for
you already um it's a bit of a it's a
bit of a section but i think it
encapsulates a little bit what we've
already talked about and then what i
would like to move further into and just
to give a little bit of context we are
we are
sort of
happening with iphamilo the main
character and her partner kurt
and they are reflecting on
race on
his white family on experiences as such
and of blackness in culture
okay i should say that i haven't read
this in years and so so it might be fun
when musa gave me the homework um
backstage i looked at it and i thought
my goodness i wrote that anyway
so
and yet
once
they visited his aunt claire in vermont
a woman who had an organic farm and
walked around barefoot and talked about
how connected to the earth it made her
feel
did ephemera have such an experience in
nigeria she asked
and looked disappointed when a family
said her mother would slap her if she
ever stepped outside without shoes
claire talked throughout the visit
about her kenyan safari
about mandela's grace
about her adoration for harry belafonte
and if emily worried that she would
lapse into ebonics of swahili
as they left her rambling house ifemelu
said i bet she's an interesting woman
if she would just be herself i don't
need her to overassure me that she likes
black people
and kurt said it was not about race it
was just that his aunt was hyper aware
of difference any difference
she would have done the same exact thing
if i had turned up with a blonde russian
he said
of course his aunt would not have done
the same thing with a blonde russian
a blonde russian was white
and his aunt would not feel the need to
prove that she liked people who looked
like the blonde russian
but if hermelo did not tell kurt this
because she wished it were obvious to
him
when they walked into a restaurant with
linen covered tables and the host looked
at them and asked kurt
table for one
kurt hastily told her the host did not
mean it like that
and she wanted to ask him
how else could the host have mentored
when the strawberry head owner of the
bed and breakfast in montreal refused to
acknowledge her as they checked in
a steadfast refusal smiling and looking
only at kurt
she wanted to tell kurt how slighted she
felt
was because she was unsure whether the
woman disliked black people
or liked kurt
but she did not because he would tell
her she was overreacting
or tired or both
there were
simply
times that he saw
and times that he was unable to see
she knew that she should tell him these
thoughts
that not telling him cast a shadow over
them both
still
she chose silence
until the day they argued about her
magazine
he had picked up a copy of essence from
the pile on her coffee table on a rare
morning that they spent in her apartment
the air still thick with the aroma of
the omelettes she had made
this magazine is kind of racially skewed
he said
what
come on
only black women featured
you're serious she said
he looked puzzled yeah
we're going to the bookstore
what
i need to show you something don't ask
okay he said unsure what this new
adventure was but eager with that
childlike delight of his to participate
she drove to the bookstore in the inner
harbor took down copies of the different
women's magazines from the display shelf
and led the way to the cafe
do you want a latte he asked
yes thanks
after they settled down on the chairs
paper cups in front of them
she said let's start with the covers
she spread the magazines on the table
some on top of the others
look all of them are white women
this one is supposed to be hispanic
we know this because they wrote two
spanish words here
but she looks exactly like this white
woman no difference in her skin tone and
hair and features
now i'm going to flip through page by
page and you tell me how many black
women you see
babe come on kurt said amused leaning
back paper cup to his lips
just humor me she said
and so he counted
three black women he said finally
or maybe four
she could be black
so three black women in maybe 2 000
pages of women's magazines and all of
them are biracial or racially ambiguous
so they could also be indian or puerto
rican or something
not one of them is dark not one of them
looks like me
so i can't get clues for makeup from
these magazines
look this article tells you to pinch
your cheeks for color
because oh
[Applause]
really forgotten that
[Laughter]
this article tells you to pinch your
cheeks for color because all their
readers are supposed to have cheeks you
can pinch for color
this tells you about different hair
products for everyone and everyone means
blondes brunettes and redheads
i am none of those
and this tells you about the best
conditioners for straight wavy and curly
no kinky
see what they mean by curly
my hair could never do that
this tells you about matching your eye
color and eye shadow
blue green and hazel eyes
but my eyes are black so i can't know
what shadow works for me
this says that this pink lipstick is
universal
but they mean universal if you're white
because i would look like a [ __ ] if
i try that shade of pink
oh look
here's some progress
an advertisement for foundation there
are seven different shades for white
skin
and one generic chocolate shade
but that is progress
now let's talk about what is racially
skewed
do you see why a magazine like essence
even exists
thank you
how was it uh how was it re-reading
that that was written in 2014.
um no it was actually
wait it's been longer than that
it's been ages
no i i am no i loved reading it i just i
had forgotten
actually honestly i thought that was
quite clever yeah
exactly
[Applause]
i thought you know she's not too bad
yeah
well first of all it's it's it's really
clever but second of all i think using
that
um
that sort of cultural lens to talk about
injustice was was a very very effective
i think tool as well how what kind what
role does that play in your work in
general sort of
showing us showing us things through
through or showing us
uncomfortable things and uncomfortable
truths
through things that we know from our
everyday lives how are you how are you
still working with that you know i
i think we don't live in a vacuum as
humans so the reason i think that i'm
drawn in particular to a certain kind of
realistic fiction
as a reader and as a writer
is because i think it's the kind of
fiction that
understands that we humans are you know
we're deeply emotional beings but we are
also situated socially and politically
and it's important to recognize that you
know i think
whether you live in a place where you
can afford your rent
shapes the way you look at the world you
know whether you live in a place where
if you go out on the street you're
worried that a police officer will just
automatically assume that you're guilty
of something shapes the way you look at
the world and also i think shapes your
internal life
and so i'm really interested in
portraying characters in their fullness
and often it means writing about things
that are not
easy
or comfortable but i've always felt that
we shouldn't look away
and i think it's important if we want to
change the world and i think i have a
um i unfortunately have a very strong
messiah complex um
elaborate on that please
which has not always served me well but
i can't help it so i want to fix the
world you know this is the thing i want
um and i sort of have this you know
ridiculous i want everyone to be happy i
want justice i want and if we in general
want to fix the world we have to look at
the things that are uncomfortable and i
think literature can help us do that
you know i read
you know i read balzac
and i'm thinking goodness
this is showing me
um french society as it was with all of
its um
you know all of its sort of complexities
and it also shows you the failures in
that society i hope that my my
literature does that for for
contemporary times right
i i remember reading um
that you um or it's actually not reading
it's listening because you said it
specifically in
the danger at the end you have a single
story that it rubs people of dignity and
so
doing this kind of work and doing this
kind of literature is also a way of
repairing dignity or building dignity i
think that when you give people back
actually it already belongs to them but
when you
create
paths
for people to reclaim
things that have been taken from them
yes i think we can repair dignities that
are broken and so i can talk for example
as a person who
is african and i know that for so long
the stories of my continent were told by
people who were not african
and and as a child you're growing up and
you're reading these stories in which
people who look like you are always kind
of the bad guys
um i remember a friend of mine from
kenya talking about how when he was
growing up and he was reading these
books by writer haggard i think and how
he always identified with the white
people because the black people were
also just stupid
and you're a child and you're innocent
in the face of a story but it's doing
something to you mentally because
because at some point you start to think
that if everybody who looks like you is
portrayed this way then there might be a
problem
with looking like you you know
and and so for me it then becomes
important
to tell the truth you know and and so i
don't believe in telling only positive
stories i think that's also often quite
as
reductive
and i think it's also dehumanizing so i
often joke about how i do not like the
magical negro stories you know where all
the black people are wonderful and
everybody is a king or a queen and it's
just so boring black people are human
right they should be allowed that full
complex humanity for so long in in the
history of storytelling in our world
they haven't been allowed that and so i
think that it's a gesture of returning
dignity if we tell full complex
human
stories of people from you know this
continent that i love yeah and also the
people and
and also you know and also the the
the diaspora because one of the things
that's really been very
you know exciting for me is learning
about the african diaspora you know
learning about all the black people in
latin america you know black people in
brazil in colombia in in peru right and
also that there is a black diaspora in
europe i mean i remember going to italy
some years ago and talking to black
italians and it just really broke my
heart this young woman who you know had
been born in italy raised there and she
said
they don't see me
and i remember writing that down because
i write things that i you know hoping
that you know i might use it in a story
but there was something about it that
made me think
how can we how can we use storytelling
to get to a place where this young woman
feels that her country sees her
i think being being being part myself of
the diaspora here as well and being been
being born here with a with a father
from from the comoros
so for those who don't know where that
is it's a little group of islands
between madagascar and tanzania um
i think it's not only the sort of the
the rebuilding dignity it's also being
there in the first place of of showing
that i think in it in a danish context
at least it it isn't just the fact that
we have historically have not have only
seen
black people or or people of color
people that i could reflect myself in
as
stupid or as bad or as you know criminal
it was also that that were none
um and
and i think
working with that now in in in where we
are that's also one of the reasons that
i wanted to highlight this section from
americana is because i think things
in this in this place in the world at
least
have changed just a little bit in that
there there are actually
a much more sort of visual side to the
diaspora to the black community here
and a lot of that i think a lot of that
narrative and a lot of that
understanding
i think is
is reflected in in that because the
visual side has also started to change
we have found each other we are talking
to each other um
there will be a new show coming this
year on on on dr the national broadcast
company with
mostly a black cast that takes place in
a hair salon i mean
if that is not sort of a very direct
link to to sort of a window into what
you are also writing about there
um i don't know what is
but then at the same time oh sorry
no yeah i was just thinking about you
know the word
slave you know i mean the the deans did
build slave forts in west africa okay
absolutely just saying i just wanted to
make sure that that was
absolutely absolutely because the reason
i say that is when just talking about
the invisibility of black people i'm
thinking well 250 years ago you had
forts on the west coast of africa so
what did you do like i mean all of all
of the inner city has built on a lot of
it at least it's built on on wealth that
that is that is reclaimed from that i
think you are you're pointing to a
conversation that
that in a danish context is still
proving very difficult to be to to even
start which is sort of confronting
ourselves with with a colonial past
but i think that's also one of the
topics that i'm fascinated about how you
unfold so sort of
uh the complexities of that the very
still
stark reality of sort of of of of how
uh
a lot of of countries in the african uh
continent nigeria and in in particular
of course in your writing
is still
sort of
living with that story in in actuality
uh going back to half of on your first
book for example
how
how do you
sort of
consider
taking those elements that you know are
so uncomfortable but so true
and think about how they will be
sort of received in the world when you
send it out as as a truth do you do you
write it
no i don't think about how it will be
received and i in general i think that
anybody who wants to write and i say
this to my students when i teach is do
not think about your audience
because you're going to censor yourself
right you're not you will it's it's
human nature i think and so i just i do
not think about audience
in particular with americana and when i
finished i was kind of prepared that
everybody would hate it
but at the same time i thought this is
the book i wanted to write and so i
didn't have any regrets and i have to
say that i was so pleasantly surprised
that americans liked it so suddenly i
thought i really like americans no
no but i
i no i don't think about again i just i
really feel that
um
we have to be adults about life in other
words we cannot expect everything to be
comfortable
right and um
and i i'm willing i'm willing to that
sometimes there are consequences to
writing about things that make people
uncomfortable and i'm willing to to face
those consequences if it means that
somebody will say i'm never going to
read her book again then that's fine but
the thing is i'm writing what i really
believe in and most of all i think
intention matters
so i think it's important that we
confront history so that we can make our
present and our future better
it's not confronting history for the
sake of confronting history there is in
fact a reason for this
and i think we're all products of our
history
and so which is why again i go back to
the u.s only because that's where i know
well um
this question about critical risk theory
and often people on the right the
political rights in the u.s will say
um facts don't care about your feelings
right that's what they say to people on
the left and it seems to me that this is
a subject in which people on the left
can say that to them you know facts do
not care about your feelings race is a
thing here are the facts you know
um
and it also shouldn't be about feelings
i sometimes think that maybe that's part
of the problem that
there's a certain level of privilege
that one
has in the world that one then feels
entitled
to endless comfort
endless emotional and mental comfort
so
you know from this place of privilege
which is also i think quite a selfish
place
people will think i do not want to have
to think about my great grandfather
selling people because i didn't do it
yeah but your great grandfather did and
it's a fact and it's you know so if we
are going to for example celebrate all
the historical feats
we have to celebrate the other side um
i know i'm just thinking about what does
denmark celebrate
about its history
because i mean i know that all of them
seriously i mean all of this sort of
infighting so it was did sweden colonize
denmark
sort of back and forth and back and
forth and back and forth back
scandinavia
so so the so i'm sure the residual
resentments right
um
so in the pecking order i think it's
sweetened denmark then poor norway that
suddenly got oil money is that kind of
anyway my point depend what depends what
lens we're looking at
oh muslim's danish patriotism is coming
out there we go
um but really just to say
what
it seems to me the norm is to celebrate
all the kind of good things yeah that
were done historically
which is fine i think that's wonderful
but
but if we only do that then we're lying
you know if you if you tell half a story
you're lying yeah and so i think it's
important in addition to celebrating
whatever you know denmark conquered i
don't know where
also to talk about the other things
because only then can you have the full
story so that's kind of my
that's sort of my just that's how i i'm
really keen to tell the full story yeah
you've i think that's very very
beautiful and you've contextualized that
maybe
very personally in in in your latest
book the essay notes on grief
and
one thing that
struck me when i read it was the
was the sentence and it's in the first
part of the book but grief is an unkind
form of education
that i think was
so poignant and so beautiful
would you maybe elaborate a little bit
on that because
the education part of it i think is also
important in that context
um
yeah grief taught me
reforced lessons on me
and
and it was horrible
um
i think before
my before my father died
it's been two years it's still very
strange to say my father died
you know i had experienced grief
friends i loved who had died my
grandmothers had died
but not i mean my father was
my father was the center for me my
father was my life's uncle
and
when he died i was just
i came undone
i really did
and i didn't expect to
i think i i just imagine that grief
is kind of the sadness
you know um longing emptiness
but suddenly i was
learning that it's also about anger and
it's about resenting other people
and it's about sometimes even being
angry with the person who has died
and
you know all of these things and i
i just felt that i was being educated in
just the most cruel way you know
um
but it's also an education that you
cannot escape you know if you've been
fortunate to love deeply and then you
lose it's it
you just have to you you will go through
that horrible cruel education that grief
is
and how has how has that or how has that
been afterwards
sort of giving that to the world and and
making that up a sort of
both a glimpse into into your personal
uh into your personal feelings but also
in a way sort of educating others about
the role that that grief can have
i hoped you know when i started writing
this essay i remember thinking i would
just i would just show it to my siblings
and then at some point i thought no i
want to publish it not just because i
wanted to celebrate this magnificent man
that i called my father but also because
i hoped it would help other people
grieving right because
the kind of discovering all of these
i thought i'm sure there are other
people in the world out there who are
not just grieving but who are taken
aback
by all of the
complexities of their grief and that
maybe if they read this they will think
i'm not alone and i really think that
often
the most important thing that stories
can do for us is to remind us that we're
not alone you know there's just
something about
about life that you know life can be
tough and so i think it's comforting to
know that you're not alone and
yeah but it's difficult i mean even
writing about writing about grief is
difficult
and
i think this book is quite different
from other things i've done because
i wasn't protecting myself
so in my fiction even even when i used
things that happened to me i never used
them quite as they happened you know um
and when i write essays i'm always sort
of
i don't let i'm there's a sense in which
i i protect myself i i protect my
privacy i
but with this i just i wrote i just
rooted it just came out and i didn't
want to hold anything back
and i think that's something else that
grief does there's a sense in which it
makes you so much more vulnerable
changes you
um
and also i think clarifies things for
you
my father died and shortly after my
mother died so it was just utter
devastation for us my siblings and me
but one of the things it did for me was
also to clarify what matters you know
you suddenly think
we're we're so fragile like you know we
could just die tomorrow and that would
be it
and
so because of that what really matters
so it really clarified things for me
good and bad ways what does matter
friendship love honesty
um
and so there are people so there were
people i reached out to
to mend
things that were broken
and then there were people i thought i
do not need this person in my life
so grief really does clarify things
yeah
i think
sort of on a person on a personal note
sort of reading this um
sort of quite quite recently after after
losing a very beloved family member
myself as well it felt like like you did
that that you kind of reached out um and
and taught something
and
the thing that struck me as well was how
in in the last couple of years i mean
this has also been presented as sort of
as as a as a text that
that that that bound people together
that were said in the introduction
during the pandemic sort of in a lot of
people's lives there was grief and there
was loneliness
as well
how
do you
feel about sort of the individual grief
in a way becoming
an emblem of a collective grief if you
could say because i think there's a sort
of a dynamic between those two there
well i'm always happy when anything
individual becomes an emblem of
something collective
because
you know because i'm a believer in sort
of universal humanity i mean i i kind of
say that mock half mockingly but i
really do believe that i really do
believe that fundamentally in the end
um
human beings really are similar we
really are you know
um
i think the pandemic
yeah i mean i don't know if this
made people i mean i if it did i'm happy
to hear that
yeah
in terms of in terms of that becoming an
emblem i find that interesting because
as i mentioned in the beginning um
angela davis was here um two weeks ago
in conversation with raniere de lodge
the journalist and writer who famously
wrote
why i'm no longer talking to white
people about race
um
we said that at the same time cheers
um
and one of the things that that i found
interesting in in their talk it was
about abolition was how
angela davis this this sort of
iconic activist and
felt about fame
and about being that sort of emblem for
something that has always been a
collective effort and
it made me it made me wonder
how not just you sort of react to fame
but also how you become sort of an
emblem of all of your stories that all
of course you write them but they are
all stories that are about family that
are about cultures that are about
human existences and about
collectiveness so to say
what did she say about
about that yes well i think very
interestingly um and and some of the
other people in the audience that were
there may correct me if i'm wrong if i
remember uh wrongly but but she said
that that she had struggled with it a
lot that it was something that i mean
fighting for
a just world and fighting for a cause
and fighting to oppose a system
isn't something you do because you want
fame
and then
when you get it
you have to realize i think she and i'm
paraphrasing again think
talked about how she had to realize that
the fame was never her
as a as a it wasn't whether or not she
was a nice person or you know how she
lived her everyday life it was what she
represented it was the action the
movement in in society and i think that
was a very sort of
beautiful description maybe of of that
role
yeah that's me that's exactly me too
she's um no she's she really is just
remarkable i remember having a
lovely lovely afternoon some years ago
in her house with her and some friends
that she's
um i do think she's she's an icon she's
just utterly iconic absolutely um
and i think you know and i think that's
a lovely response that she gave but i
also think it's very modest because you
know there are
it does take
something it takes a kind of courage
um because there are consequences for
her right and
so she made choices knowing that
she would lose out on certain things but
she still made those choices because she
believed in something so i think
um i'm not this is the reason i don't
like being called an activist
i think the real activists actually did
real things
and i just sort of you know
write things
um in nigeria activists are killed i
mean you know we had we had a military
dictator who killed ken sarah we were
who was an activist and so sometimes it
seems to me that activist is a war that
i haven't quite earned
um i
i'm happy to be called a
i guess maybe a public thinker maybe but
really fundamentally i want to be a
writer that's all i really want to be
and
fame is such a
i love that quote um and i think it's
ryoka
fame is the sum of the misunderstandings
that surround a person
and i think that's so true i mean fame
fame is about something that's not you
like there's the you who you know goes
home and
and hugs your family and and you know um
you call your friends and you laugh and
you argue and then there's the you that
people make up
and
[Music]
it often is quite strange actually
but on the other hand
i mean there are some
i think
i mean you know i talked about having
this messiah complex and using my
platform so there's a sense in which
being well known sometimes can give you
an opportunity to do what matters to you
and so because of that you kind of learn
to live with the other less
appealing
parts of of being famous which also can
mean that people misunderstand you
sometimes deliberately so and people
think that somehow fame means that you
you no longer hurt
you know
um and actually in some ways it can make
you even more fragile
i made a choice some years ago um
to let go of
what i think often comes with fame which
is paranoia especially in this internet
age
where um suddenly a friend calls and
tells you i'm so sorry they said
something about you and suddenly you
think five million people are waiting
outside your house with um
you know guns or something to shoot you
and
it's never fun right but
but there are advantages as well and you
use them so i'm grateful that i can talk
about what i care about and that
hopefully somebody listens
and also i have to say that when i'm in
restaurants in lagos people always pay
for my food
so that
if nothing else that is one reason to be
famous
i asked for my check and they're like oh
my damn somebody paid for it i'm like
all right okay
[Laughter]
i like that uh i like i like
it must be nice
um
and you know it's nice just when they do
not come to say hello yeah they just pay
and go yeah that's the best thing
take notes um
i would uh
i would like to elaborate a little bit
on that on that um
on on what you just said about not being
an activist but being
a right or not having earned that label
at least
is there
then
maybe a difference between being an
activist and someone who just speaks up
is is that it or
because i think you are speaking up you
are talking about all of these
uncomfortable truths
but also from a different position
actually i think that's a good question
i would maybe say yes but i think also i
think my positioning so i i grew up in
nigeria i grew up under military
dictatorships i grew up
um
seeing
what it meant to live in a in a society
that was really repressive where my my
parents and their friends who were all
university academics
would speak in whispers even inside our
homes when they were talking about the
government
and i also saw what it meant for
journalists for example
i remember as a child
when this journalist in nigeria um
delegiwa was was killed when somebody
sent him a letter bomb he opened it blew
him up and lots of people were certain
that it was the government and
he was writing about you know corruption
and that sort of thing and so i think in
my mind
activist then means a person who
i mean there's a certain i think a
certain kind of um
i guess drama no not drama drama
trivializes it um
i don't know i just feel as though i
haven't done enough to earn it i mean
but it's not
i don't even really need to
but the thing is i do make the choice to
talk about these things and i know that
it would be much easier if i didn't
right
i'd like to tell a story about this
young man in lagos who
at an event i did years ago and he he
said to me
um i really used to like you when you
just wrote novels i love purple hibiscus
and then he says but when you started
talking about this feminism thing and
this gay thing
i stopped liking you
and then he went on to ask me what do
you plan to do to make me start liking
you again right
and i think he meant you know you need
to shut up about gay rights and feminism
and i think this was just about the time
when the nigerian government had passed
this horrendous law that makes it
criminal
to be gay yeah
which still stands in nigeria by the way
right
and so i'd written about it and you know
really just wanted to let people know
how just immoral this was and so i think
this guy wanted me to say i don't know
maybe that i take back what i wrote or
something
so i said to him you know
yeah keep your like. right i don't need
it but but the point is um
and and not necessarily to appeal to
people like that young man but to say
that of course if i didn't talk about
certain things
um it would be easier yeah but i
wouldn't sleep so well at night
there we go is that something then
because i remember in your um
in the feminist manifesto
with 15 suggestions that you've written
to your uh to your to your friend who's
asking you how to raise her kid feminist
one of those suggestions is realize that
someone will not like you yes
does that come from that
from that incident
i think no from many other incidents
right um oh no i you know i was when i
think about it now even as a child in
primary school and you know i have to be
fair and say that looking back i can't
see
how i could conceivably have been an
annoying child
right that was very diplomatic however
so you know i would ask questions and
teachers would respond and i would be
like no that's a bit too simple and i
would push and teachers would get
annoyed and and you know i imagine now
i can see you know this really annoying
little
[ __ ] who just will not stop
and so i think i learned very early on
not everybody will like you
and that it's okay
you know it really is okay i think this
is something particularly for women um
where we're raised as as you know from
when you're a little girl not only to be
nice and but also to think that you need
to always please people and you always
need people to like you
and you don't so when i talk to young
women i say to them all the time
somebody will like you you the world is
diverse and somebody will like you and
also i say to them think about yourself
as a person who can like and dislike
it's not just that you're an object that
oh here like no you can also dislike
them so you know my thing is if you
don't like me i don't like you right so
it's nobody's loss
no yeah
[Applause]
but no but really i mean i don't want to
sound too glib
it's not
obviously i'm not suggesting that it's
easy
to deal with
knowing that there's negativity directed
at you it's never easy right
but i think um you know
you kind of think about what matters
again for me and so it matters to me
where the negativity is coming from and
why
so this young man
who says i don't like you because you
talk about gay rights and feminism
actually
don't care about his liking me you know
it doesn't matter to me there are times
when
um
you know being disliked by a certain
sort of group or people can hurt a bit
more because sometimes when it's your
tribe during the disliking it can be
hurtful but still you know you kind of
know that you sleep well at night and i
think it makes up for it it also helps
to have you know
a really hot husband who loves you
friends
a family that is very supportive you
know those help a great career
can't imagine
i think i think maybe that's
that's a very important thing to to take
away as well in
in our conversation right here in
denmark i think
in in in a danish context or in a danish
culture at least
uncomfortability is something
we have a very difficult time with and
so the sort of the policing thing
maybe especially for women but obviously
i can't talk on behalf of women but
maybe especially for women but i think
for
for for society in general here
it's a very difficult thing it's very
consensus seeking all the time we all
have to agree we all have to like each
other we all have to be merry and you
know jolly and
and even sorry to interrupt even
sometimes the way i i think in addition
to that there's often an acceptable way
of talking about difficult things yeah
and that itself can be very troubling
yeah so in the us i'm often just deeply
resentful and
sort of i just do not accept this idea
that the story of race must always be
one of progress
so
in the u.s both the left and the right
will say oh look how terrible things are
but look how far we've gone let's
celebrate that and i'm thinking no you
should never have been racist in the
first place you don't get a cookie you
know yeah so so this idea that that
no worry it's true
so i feel as though um
it's not just that
we need to create room to talk about
things we also need to let go of that
idea that there has to be one way to
talk about it and that that way has to
end with everyone holding hands you know
we can be uncomfortable and and we have
to make room for anger yeah and maybe
you also realize that if we are talking
about sort of
a diversity of humans and of existence
this
and experiences the goal isn't
necessarily for all of us to be the same
or to feel the same at the same time it
is a goal in itself to be able to
hold all of that
difficulty at the same time i think you
describe that in americana very well
when you're you're writing about how uh
um how if a melo is is is making money
of her blog and is starting to do sort
of diversity work speaking engagement
talking about that and people tell her
she's racist
and she realizes that they don't want to
hear
about injustice they want to hear
something that comforts themselves
which i think is so true for a lot of
the
the conversations that are going on here
as well
we've been around
big topics i think we've covered uh
and and
and a lot of different truths and we
have we have 15 minutes left
i would like to
to end on maybe hopefully indulge me
a positive note
i'm all for positivity
um because i because i read uh as well
that that you uh
that you or you said that at the time i
don't know if it if it holds any longer
but that you considered yourself a
pessimistic optimist i think was the
uh was the was the phrase
but if we are to
to end if you are to
to to point us in a direction that you
find hopeful
or places that you are looking for
to find hope
what would that be
yes i and thank you musa i really love
how you asked the question which is you
said this and i don't know if you still
feel that way it's so refreshing
because you know you say something 20
years ago when you were drunk and then
someone someone comes to me is like you
said this well and i'm thinking i don't
even remember you know i'm like i'd had
two glasses of wine have a light head
so thank you you're welcome
and yes i still i would still describe
myself as an optimist as a pessimistic
optimist and i think it's really just my
way of saying fundamentally i do i think
i'm a hopeful person
but at the same time i'm a realistic
person so i think maybe that's what i
mean about the pessimistic part i don't
believe in um i'm very suspicious of
excessive
anything
you know excessive happiness excessive i
just feel like it's not real
um but in general i think i am hopeful i
i believe in trying i believe that we
can remake the world i really believe
that
and i think it's really just for lack of
political will and effort there's so
much about the way the world is that i
just think it doesn't have to be
right not that we will create a perfect
you know existence but it doesn't have
to be as bad as it is and i mean in all
kinds of ways economic inequality and
you know the way that capitalism is
practiced now the
you know racial injustice
you know women's rights all of those
things minority rights all of those
things
and um
men's rights
all right i'm joking i'm joking
we don't want to keep we don't want to
exclude anyone um
[Music]
but but you know to your question where
do i look um
poetry
seriously
stories
and there are stories that there are
things going on in the world i think
that are reasons to hope
often we don't hear them
as
frequently as we hear the other things
you know
um
so you know again i talked about this um
congolese doctor's book i'm reading
um
you know and there's so many stories
like that people who do things that
that change
things in the world and so i look to
those for hope and i also i have to say
really believe that
human beings are
generally kind of more okay than not
and
and i think i've always believed that
and so
what leads you to saying then
um
i don't know i think maybe the way that
one is raised really shapes the way you
know it's that sort of that old argument
about is the glass half full or half
empty i think the way that you know
growing up in a family just really
cocooned by love
and
um my parents were just really lovely
people and my childhood was really happy
and
and even though i was very alert to
injustice as a child i was also very
secure i think that kind of makes you
i don't know believe in possibility
maybe
my life experiences have not always been
wonderful but they haven't they haven't
left me flattened like i get up and i
still think
you know what we can still do better
right and
and i want to change
this a small slice of the world so when
i when i talk to and i mean the smallest
thing so
um
i remember a woman at the airport in
lagos
telling me how her husband
had been terrible to her and how he was
upset that she was reading my book
because i'm a feminist
which somehow i think is a synonym for
devil in his world
and you know she was complaining and i
said to her let's call him
and she's like what i was like yep i
want to talk to him so she calls him and
i talk to him for 15 minutes maybe
he's an igbo man i'm imo and i know how
to sort of appeal to a certain kind of
igbo male
fragile ego
so i appeal to it and then i have an
opening so i start talking to him about
gender and women and at the end of the
call he's like
i don't completely agree with you but
you have a few good points
and you know i felt so happy because i
thought
this woman's life will be slightly
better he might be less of an [ __ ]
because of this conversation i had right
right yeah and so for me that's that's i
mean so when i talk about change i don't
mean grand things they don't have to be
yeah i mean yeah
i think thank you for sharing that for
sharing that
in the in the first place i think
i at least would like to to know then
what you
what kind of of of next few bits you
would like to to work on changing
so many bits um
let's start from one end and
um honestly in nigeria
i would like inc collectively for to
walk on
the reduction of hypocrisy
i would like to
work for the recognition of the human
full humanity of gay people on the
african continent in general but in
nigeria in particular
in nigeria in particular um
because you know sometimes i think
it's easy especially when you're looking
at it from a western lens to think oh
you know now the same sex marriage
everything is fine but it's not and and
i think in particular for this continent
that i love right
um and of course
women's issues are
front and center for me i so the small
things i would like
to remove the pregnancy penalty
that so many women deal with at work
um
to better acknowledge
the reality of what it is to have a
female body
i see that as somebody who
whose life was deeply deeply changed by
pregnancy and childbirth
and i hadn't quite realized you know and
so
now i'm like
i think we need to have a ministry
um
of
female affairs
where
i'm not even joking where
i mean how is it that we can how is it
that we can in this world
um
transplant hearts
but we cannot
solve
pmdd and pms
well i think maybe historically because
every ministry has been a ministry of
male affairs yeah so i want to change
that that's that yeah i want to change
that i want i want the world to stop
being modeled on maleness but instead be
modeled on both
so so it's a very long list as you can
see
it's one it's one step at a time it is
right it's one step at a time if you're
also doing things well thank you
and you know right isn't he
thank you and
and you must also know that sometimes
you you want to change everything in one
full swoop and you know you can't so you
make choices absolutely but i think one
of one of the things and i think that's
the reason that example you gave earlier
so
it's so poignant is that that
in these very polarizing and polarized
times as you as you mentioned in the
beginning
that glimpse of of
human hope i think maybe is the best way
to describe it that it is when someone
says
i'm not sure i 100 agree but i actually
hear what you're saying
that's a that's such a rare thing for
people to say these days which is very
frightening i think yes and and i think
so many things in in your in in the
whole catalog of of work that you've
done
is helping sort of dismantling those
things maybe because they give people
tools to go out and do them themselves
what
would what would you
hope
to talk about if you were to come back
in this stage in eight years
and
[Music]
and rejoice hopefully
um
i don't know
well i'm hoping it will be maybe four
years not eight
um i'm only saying eight no i know i'm
kidding i know of course it's a
wonderful symmetry yeah i hope you guys
like it
but i i think i'm also kind of poking
fun of myself and hoping i would have
finished the book in the next four years
that's kind of what yeah
um what would i like to talk about what
would i i'm hoping that in the next
eight years i suppose
that we will have less
to
be pessimistic about in general that if
i had the conversation with you
that i wouldn't feel as i do that you
are burdened
by
so many of the things
that are realities in
denmark
yeah so in eight years i would um
yeah hope that you would have less to do
i mean i was struck by what you said
about it's not just
um telling the different stories it's
also just about being visible
and you said and i love that line
we know each other now we don't talk to
each other i found that very moving
and i'm hoping that in eight years
it won't be as poignant it will be more
ordinary yeah
yeah
i uh i i second that i also hope it
doesn't it won't take
eight years again
um
and i think
that one thing
sort of to to
to to end on as well maybe is
is that that
reality of the everyday maybe if the
ordinary um and and the way that that
you are showcasing that to us in in all
of your works i think has has literally
been
also from a personal experience here
a
a sort of a way of showing that hope of
showing that this is also just an
everyday reality but it is real
and it is important
and thank you so much for giving us that
and for sharing that with us
thank you
thank you
hmm
thank you so much
exactly
thank you everyone
can i get the mic on thank you
everyone
thank you
thank you so much
thank you this is this is heartwarming
indeed yes
don't leave because in a little while
you will be fortunate enough to get your
book signed in there for you
[Applause]
thank you and have a good night
you